speaking of uh recording policies i
don't know if this is going on youtube
or not uh i don't i don't know
okay okay wow okay so um you know be
advised speaking of recording policies
that this
uh
something will be a recorded session
work session public session
uh and on
uh the representative luna was in the
house i just started talking dave and uh
i didn't realize that speaking of
recording policies that apparently this
is going to be recorded on youtube is is
a public work session so given that
i want to make sure i speak
in good english and that type of thing
so to set this up again as i just
started to do hb 1295
we were all here for the uh it was i was
a prime sponsor so
you may recall i introduced the bill
months ago
and explained the intent behind the bill
uh months ago we had a lot of questions
the day that we uh or that i introduced
it
and we spoke about it not that much an
executive session and and
it fairly quickly was recommended to
interim study
so
as i'm setting this up let me just
compare this as i did when i introduced
the bill the first time to um
the gifted student bill it's it's the
same
concept true truly uh this bill has no
policy this bill has no policy mandate
uh and no spending requirement
um and does everybody have a copy i have
one extra if you don't or you can
certainly pull it up
if you don't have you can put it up
online
very very short
and again to
set this up a little bit it's uh
kind of modeled on the gifted student
bill which similarly had as i said no
policy mandate no spending requirement
and all that did and all this does is
ask the districts the new hampshire
school districts
to
share with doe
much in the same fashion as the gifted
bill
their policies in terms of
recording
classroom recording media policies
visitation policies and that type of
thing
um and i want to thank representative
hobson and representative ford for
coming in um and representative luna uh
those three were not in the list that
chairman ladd put out as
having been assigned to this
um so appreciate them swinging by as
well
so
the
the gifted bill uh deb i want to thank
you for representative hobson for
sending me the link uh as i mentioned
before d.o.e
uh in response to uh hb 321 which was
the gifted bill
has put out uh
guidance or recommendations um
attorney defender's award for that uh
when you when d.o.e sends out a
guy
that's it yeah so
the technical advisory for the gifted
bill 321 which is no statute has been
sent out to all the schools in um
hobbs and send me the link to i looked
at is very at least for me hopefully for
all of us it's very exciting to see
that
uh in response to the statute
simply asking districts to uh share what
if anything they're doing for for gifted
students
uh with with doe for the so-called best
practices folder we spent a lot of now
the reason they mentioned the gifted
bill is because that
two terms ago when it first was
introduced it was my bill originally two
terms ago uh that bill was sent to
interim study and there were seven of us
who met and talked and linked about it
um
uh and trying to think barbra shaw
was
i think she chaired the committee
actually she did she chaired the uh
the work session interim study committee
on gifted students
and so
the subcommittee after talking about it
dan wolf was on that
dave doherty was on there trying to
think who else was anyway
the committee voted
recommended five to two
on the gifted bill to
have that move forward
with recommendation and ultimately otp
um
and so in the fall
and
uh
patty and lynn the representative
cornell up santana will recall
it came to the full community of the
fall
not for anything other than to have the
committee review the subcommittee's
recommendation
and uh i recall representative shaw made
the motion to support otp for that
representative guile uh seconded it
and uh i have to smile because uh
robertson milo was there and he looked
at me at the time i don't think mel
was necessarily for it but after barbara
and then mary moved it he
he at that time voted to support
otp on the gifted bill
but that was just a recommendation in
the fall of 2018 and then there was
another election and i i wasn't here
representative
lang tried to keep that going didn't
move forward the next session
but we brought it back this past session
um and because of the time that we spent
on it and having the the precedent of
interim study
the impermitor from interim study for
that bill it uh
passed committee passed the house passed
senate became law and it's uh i think
and i hope that that bill
is really making a difference every
district in the state now is is at least
thinking about um better identifying and
supporting gifted students so this is
the same type of concept 1295 just
asking schools
to look at their policy reports now
again i'm doing more talking i plan but
i do want to set this up prop properly
and thoroughly
so this bill 1295
asking for reports and what prompted
this uh
the covid thing the covet situation
really had a lot to do with us because
as you all know
during the covet pandemic situation
every school had to
come up with a plan to go remote
and these remote plans
in many cases most cases involved
some sort of
media obviously
you know classroom recordings uh
hybrid policies
youtube's uh you know zoom conferences
whatever
so
very much uncharted waters and some of
the concerns that came up out of these
remote classes uh understandably had to
do with you know privacy issues for
teachers and students and participants
for example and again i'm repeating
stuff that
we talked about in the hearing and exec
session
but many folks obviously including
myself because they put the bill in
originally
uh what about
these
these uh zoo zoom classes that are
people can sign in on presumably with
some with a password or whatever
but what if somebody records a classroom
zoom session what is what are the
implications of that for
all concern for the students
if a student is participating remotely
in a zoom conference or a call or course
and speaks up or whatever or the teacher
speaks up now on one hand
there's some good things about that
because if you record it and you miss
the zoom class then you can play it back
and catch up and i think there's some
real merit to that and good things about
that
to tie that into here
if this is being recorded i guess it is
from what jennifer said
uh then this will be out there i guess
forever
i guess on youtube or until
youtube goes away whatever
so the
the good part of that is that people can
go back and listen to these house
sessions house hearings or classes
but the concern is
uh what if a student a young person a
minor
gives expression to something that they
wish they could take back well they
can't uh you know what we say and have
said on all these countless house
hearings and house sessions is out there
for good
so
uh
our students and teachers
that are doing remote classes hybrid
classes zoom classes
do they fully understand uh the
implications of participating in a in a
remote class
uh
so anyway uh
presumably every school district every
school every teacher every class that
does remote
learning has a policy uh or not what if
they don't or what if there
is something wrong with the policy
so as with the gifted bill to have a
requirement a statutory requirement for
districts to share
uh with doe
what they what their policy is for
remote learning for for classes also
what if a parent want wanted to or did
in some cases
you know if there's quarantine
situations
if a parent wanted to come to a to
school
to pick up
uh hard copies or materials for their
student
you know
are there policies allowing for parents
to
go to the school to pick up materials i
i don't know
it seems reasonable
but we
during the pandemic we hear
questions about parents or students or
you know when the school shut their
doors
uh
can can things be mailed uh again i i'm
not pushing any policy we're not pushing
any policy but we do want to
uh
through these reports that would come in
if this ever moves forward
identify some of the
bad practices to avoid and good
practices to emulate so that's the
intent behind this
so that's a lot of background for this
so having said all that
uh this being a work session
on this bill
1295 requiring school districts to
report in classroom observer policies
and in classrooms
video streaming and recording policies
to the department of education and also
along these lines uh again before
let's
we have other folks weigh in
these things are ubiquitous they're
everywhere uh you know i was a college
professor for many many years and on the
college level
uh and then oliver was too and most of
you have all been in classrooms
where what is the professor or the
teacher's policy with regard to in
classroom recording i know
some i can think of a amp anatomy and
physiology class
where um it was encouraged for students
if they wanted to record everything so
that they would have that those lectures
to review and study
but the implications of the college you
know college syllabuses professors have
their recording policies it's it's a
public
contract of sorts of syllabus you know
here's the policy if you're going to
take this class understand if you're
going to record these are the
constraints and recording the lectures
now for high schools again
we're hearing there's a myriad or
spectrum of
policies in terms of
uh recording
um
and
when i was in the classroom
uh the high school classroom these
things didn't exist in the college
classroom they
not that long ago everybody had these
things and i would just say okay
you know
if you want to record
for my purposes if you want to record
anything class i have no problem with it
but i don't want you to be distracted or
playing with your cell phones if you're
going to record fine if not i don't want
you doing you know
word blitz while i'm while we're having
a class
so that's another piece of this is
in class uh
policies for or policies for in class
recording there's a lot of stuff here
that i think needs to be
considered and evaluated
and
again as with the gifted bill to have
something with doe with best practices
worst practices i think is really
important really needed so there's some
background and uh who else has
any thoughts on any of this that's why
we're here
uh what's on cornell
well for one thing i i don't think the
the bill or the amendment had anything
to do with parents going in to pick up
any kind of
school work which i think is
always allowed and always has been that
if they want to go
which as long as they're given enough
notice the work is always waiting in the
office for parents to pick up and i
don't think there's that anywhere but do
you know how many districts do not have
a comprehensive video
recording because i looked up
manchester's last night and every single
one of their policies is listed on their
web page
and in the booklet that students are
given the first day of school which
parents have to sign and return that
they received every single policy
so i guess what i'm saying is i don't
know how many don't
have this um
and
to be quite honest to me this is busy
work it's busy work for the for the
district to have to do it and i think
it's busy work for the
department of ed to have to keep track
of them when if a district doesn't like
theirs or they're looking for help they
could just call the school board
association or a neighboring sau and say
hey what do you have is your policy or
even look online because if anybody
looks at manchester's you can find their
entire
policy list right there on the first
page of their website
sure great great thought great question
your first question was do i know how
many uh districts have policies in place
and i don't
they're in good on you for taking the
time to look at what manchester does i
know other folks in the room uh may or
may not have some uh
knows of what their districts do in this
area
so uh just couple quick responses um
that manchester has a
uh it sounds like
from you're looking at the website and
looking into this they have a
comprehensive uh policy
governing this
but my my question to you would be was
this policy
did it predate the recording policy or
did it predate the covert thing or is
this a policy that's been put into place
since the covid
shutdowns
it it predates it but i i think it's
comprehensive enough that it covered
what happened during shutdown because it
said if a teacher intends to create a
recording of a class
britain prior written consent must be
obtained by the parent legal guardian or
if a student parent administrator to
remember which is to create a recording
of a teacher student a class prior
written consent must be obtained from
the the teacher and the parent legal
guardian of each affected school and
and like i said these all go home the
first day of school
in the handbook that the students get
and
there's a page in it that must be signed
by the parent and the student saying
that they've written these and they
agree to them
sure
sure thank you so
i'll get right to your representative um
so my response and concern to this
though uh representative cornell this
predates uh kovit
and the recording policies that
manchester has in place uh sound
wonderful for pre-covert but what you
just described does not address hybrid
classes or zoom classes and that's kind
of part of what the impetus behind this
bill was was this new
world of remote zoom classes
and so as i explained earlier when i
spoke
probably for too long uh explaining the
impetus behind this the the zoom
aspect is not doesn't sound like that
obviously that's the policy was put in
place before covert so remote classes
and zoom classes that's a whole
issue that i try to
describe that it sounds like manchester
that's not has not addressed and perhaps
needs to i'm not saying what their
policy should be but it sounds like what
you described does not address
the
zoom youtube post covert hybrid remote
learning issue that
is of concern to some folks and my other
point i did want to make in terms of you
mentioned like busy work
i know
when the gifted bill went to the house
floor
um you know
leading up to that there were some folks
who said it's an unfunded mandate or
it's extra work or busy work or whatever
and my response to that was uh
the last thing that most of us want to
do is is give extra busy work to to
anyone anything is they have enough to
do
but if there's a policy in place whether
it's for gifted or
for
recording
uh
the requirement basically is some of
this are it could be satisfied with just
an email to the contacted doe with an
attachment saying or from ancestor
with regard to the requirement to submit
a report on gifted or media policies uh
here's an attachment to lincoln here's
what we do so from what you said there's
something in place already so
to satisfy the requirement uh i don't
see it as extra odious unfunded mandate
at all uh administrative administrative
assistant would just send an email an
attachment to doe and then
they would file it so anyway i just
wanted to respond to that in that way um
represent
i was curious there was a mandate that
um
mandated districts to post policies all
policies so there is not right i mean to
post to post online there's no policy
that says schools must do that is that
correct yeah thank you yeah that's
correct uh again as i've said a couple
of times uh
this the intent behind this very short
bill
uh was simply to create another best
practices folder no policy mandate
schools don't have to do anything policy
wise other than just share what they
what they do that's right and secondly
so you mentioned going back to the
gifted um that it's making a difference
and what
measurement is being used to say it's
making a difference the doe has this
folder versus school districts hey we
need a policy we do a search online you
can find it just like that wherever you
want you know let's say if you think you
have a school similar to
boaz is similar to bedford so they're
going to go look at bedford they're
going to go look at amherst so i'm just
wondering what tool was used for you to
say that that folder made the difference
were there do we have do we have just
follow up to that do we have numbers
that show
how much access this folder gets i mean
that's an easy tool the doe that would
be for the doe i guess the answer maybe
um is it used
sure yeah great great question
of course this is really new and the
reason i say that i and some of us are
very excited about the fact that this is
uh now in place
is that
uh qualitative you know i think you're
looking for maybe a metric or
quantitative
measure of how this gifted bill
which was the model for this bill is
making a difference and the intent of
the gift of bill for at least from my
perspective was to get
districts to
have a conversation and discussion
locally on what they could are doing or
could do to identify and support give to
students so the fact that every district
now has to look at what they're doing or
not in many cases they're not doing
anything so the fact that there's a
conversation now that inevitably is
going to happen in every district
qualitatively
that's how some of us think it's already
in the process of making a big
difference
to your question if i think i'm here
correctly you know how we
how as i said i think it's making a
difference how do i prove that um
well my answer again is the fact that
there's a discussion was the intended
bill was to get people to pay attention
and talk about gifted so does that kind
of answer your question a little bit
kind of i'm not sure
you know that those discussions have
happened i guess for me is
i'm wondering if
the
because it's in a folder
you think that that's going to
generate all kinds of talk and whatever
because it's in the doe folder i mean is
that what we're saying
you know
yeah sure um this is uh brand new uh in
fact the the date that this go gifted
goes it went into effect i'm trying to
think what it was so there'll be a
question we could answer much better in
a year after
there's been some time to see what's
come into doe and again we have a rep
from doe here
so
in the short term
i'm thrilled personally and others are
as well that every as i said every
district is now talking about something
that we think needed to be talked about
that
we think was not getting enough
attention so the fact that it's
being
uh discussed i think is a huge win at
the start now beyond that uh
representative paul i think in a year
we can
get with doe and uh and see what's come
in how many people have accessed the
the folder on best practices for gifted
uh how many really cool ideas that other
districts
that the district put in that other
districts have never thought of that
they say wow you're doing this we're
going to take and do a version of this
too
that analysis and evaluation obviously
can't take place until this has been in
in place for you know a year
and yeah i think i and hopefully all of
us will be very interested
to see uh how much um
good
flows from this but again that's we can
answer that better in a year
represent tanner
you tell me who's standing over here
thank you representative moffitt
a couple things that i wanted to bring
up um
regarding
discussing um
the policies that you were talking about
i believe i don't know that schools are
required to post them online just have
the policies have to be available to the
public so that maybe you show up at the
school or the fau office they're
available to the public
that being said um the recording the opt
out of the recording
that does predate kovid
i do remember when that came into play
that we were all required to actually
have public hearings
to discuss right whether or not this
would go into place
so maybe you'll remember better actually
my thought was at the time it kind of
morphed into whether people wanted their
children to be recorded and whether to
be on the school webpage for example at
this point social media i feel as though
that's what it morphed into and that's
what you opt out of i knew at the time
of the hearing so i can remember our
superintendent discussing with us it
originated something along the lines of
teachers that were going for advanced
degrees and they were actually recording
themselves teaching
and they were using that to kind of look
back and see how that they were doing
sort of as a review
that being said too i just wanted to
bring up something else i know we talk
about the new hampshire school board
association
quite often and they do provide a
service for sure but they are our
lobbying organization i just hope that
we refer people always back to the doe
because i think
they're the experts in this area
um and i'd like to dig deeper into the
cameras as far as
the scope of this is concerned i don't
know if we're able to or not because i
know it's not on the original bill but
um but a couple of things that i wanted
to talk about just where as far as
safety and security are concerned
we learned in texas that it probably
would have been very helpful if there
were video cameras in the classroom
and one thing that i've tossed around in
my head is you know what
maybe we don't maybe we have those um
the sound muted for example right but at
least that way
let's say there's a security officer in
the school or the local police
department at least they can see in
i'm going to take that a step further
and say that we would also need
another layer of protection because as
far as parkland is concerned their
cameras were off i want to say 27
minutes or something and that was one
thing that got them into trouble in
helping out the children the cameras are
not in real time
the other thing i'm wondering too
is we're talking about recordings for
when the teachers are doing a lesson
it's very helpful for the children to
have a recording later i i understand
that especially with covid when people
had to be out on a regular basis
i'm wondering if there was something
where yes if it was recorded we can have
the lesson recorded but if there's a way
that we could mute out maybe after the
fact before it shared
what the students are saying because i
do think the classroom needs to be a
safe area for students you're right once
it's documented it's forever i think
there's too much of a kind of gotcha out
there and these are just young kids
trying to learn and i don't want to come
up when they were 35
that they asked the question that
someone thought was ignorant or made a
comment in it to follow them so thank
you
thank you representative blitzfield
i appreciate those thoughts very much
and you'll are on a school board correct
website tanner
thank you
first of all i think
the doe has made rules that zoom can't
be
done in schools anymore
or not
that they can't be done in schools but
certainly they have a policy now that a
school can't go to zoom
uh for covet
so
i think um
you know the video policies that schools
make
they make they have made because they
have video cameras security cameras on
buses they have security cameras in
classrooms and i think um you know
kearsarge has their videos
i also think that um
you know there one of the reasons that
this was kind of put on the back burner
i think this bill
was because
once we opened the pandora's box
of this
whole issue it just went
you know really far and i think that
um
you know
what about charter schools what about
the apprentice schools and the chi
schools
that are internet schools um is there do
they have a policy or or is there a
policy for them
um you know recording students and and
their internet
uh materials and their teachers um
and
do private schools and schools receiving
voucher money are they going to be
covered in in this particular thing
because they're going to have a video
as well um
i think that
um one of the comments that you made
about uh in your opening
statement
was about how
one of the things
collecting this information is con to
identify the good and the bad
policies and
i think it would be
better in my mind
if
the doe or and i'm sure the state school
boards association has
a best practices policy for video
recordings in classrooms and that
instead of collecting from the schools
they actually
give guidance
as
to what would be some of the best
practices so um i think it you know it
goes both ways and i guess my last thing
is is time is money
and um one of the things that
you know
eight years ago when i started um my
truck here at
the house
i started because teaching
i was just totally
and and i didn't have some of the higher
um you know
over regulated teaching areas but
teaching was just in schools public
schools
it's one regulation one request
one
requirement you know no big deal
add them all up
and somebody's got to do it and that
somebody has has to do a lot of
collection and this one is major because
you're talking security cams you're
talking cameras on buses you're talking
about
cameras where teachers want um you know
or student teaching and they they need
to be videotaped you're talking about
possible zoom classes and and at this
point there's no way
if it's on the internet just like you
said with us it's no way to take it back
you know so
um and and we're not doing zoom classes
in the future um at least not unless we
want to extend the school year a lot
so i think there's a lot
that needs to be done
and perhaps
even
sent off in different bills unless
unless you wanted to require uh put
these reports required from these other
things like security cameras like uh
representative litchfield talked about
um
the prenda and kai and and the internet
classes that and even even uh vlac
um what is what's their policy and and
are they going to be required under this
to come up with a policy um
unless that's that's in the total bill
um
i i think we're missing the whole point
yeah thank you representative tanner um
so
a couple of things i
agree with i just made some notes your
points about who would be covered by
this uh and you mentioned private
schools prenda internet schools uh
charter schools uh
yeah i i think that
whatever comes out of uh this this
interim study committee or the full
committee this fall or next year
if ever or whenever
uh i agree i think that
this should be applied broadly uh
to
you know any any school that gets
public support in any fashion directly
or indirectly think that they
should submit their report but i do want
to say that
to your point about time is money i
tried to address that earlier because
this came up with the gifted program and
i said this earlier uh i
and most of us do not want to
impose any egregious administrative
burdens and you know i've been out most
of us have been out in in that world
um and
as i said earlier
this the intent of this could be in my
view um as i said before it could be
satisfied with an email an attachment so
i also want to get into i mean you flag
a lot of good
aspects bus surveillance
parking lot surveillance that type of
thing
this is what happened with the gifted
bill
um early on in fact chairman ladd um
he and i had some conversations he was
flagging all these different aspects
about gifted as you just did with this
spell
um what
we don't want to do what i don't want to
do and don't intend to do
or want to do is get into any
uh specific policies i mean
the fact that you and i are having a
little bit back and forth and some
pieces of this
that's the beauty of
that's the intent of this bill is to get
districts
on their own as much as they want to to
have discussions and conversations about
things that need to be talked about
things that need definition especially
in this new
world
so uh there again there is no there's
there is no
policy mandate there is no spending
requirement
it's basically asking for an email to go
to to do are you sure
it isn't just an email with an
attachment okay
somebody at that school let's take
kearsarge regional high school which i
or kearsarge regional has
at least
they have three different elementary
schools
okay they have a middle school and a
high school
they have a bus company
you're talking about videotaping for
example extracurriculars um
the the whole package so somebody so
they have a basic policy for in
classroom
okay on in the student handbook just
like manchester does
but
and and this videotaping and student
privacy
puts schools at risk of of lawsuits okay
so
you're
you're asking for policies where
somebody
somebody in that district whether it's a
an administrator or an administrative
secretary
has to accumulate all these different
policies that are that are throughout
the school
okay and then collate them put them in
an email and send them to the doe okay
that's what they have to do time is
money and what i'm saying is if it was
just this one
you know and i spent half an hour maybe
an hour maybe two hours maybe three
hours collating this trying to catch up
with all the video requirements we have
and giving them to the to the
administration
who then reviews them probably takes
them to the school board because now the
school board wants them and i know
that's part of your issue and then
emails them to the doe and may even have
to send them to the to the attorney
because again these types of privacy
issues put districts at risk of lawsuits
and the and so if it's going to be
published at the at the doe are going to
be accumulated at the doe that's
concerning so
so it's time and and so they've got
let's say
three four hours for this three four
hours for the civics three four hours
documenting a whole bunch of other
things plus all the special ed stuff
they have um even as a classroom teacher
you're overwhelmed with paperwork you
just keep doing paperwork and it what it
does is it takes away from your
preparation time it takes away from your
school time because you
it's it's money
so
um when you say it's not gonna you know
it's just a simple email and a pfd it's
not okay
yeah thank you representative uh again
uh honestly i i just don't see it that
way in all candor in all honesty again i
go back to representative cornell who
looked at the manchester policy uh the
intentary intent of those who uh
understand what would
we'd like to see flow from this
everything you just described is
is locally public information
so again i've said this couple of times
i just don't have the same concerns that
you do i don't we don't want to uh force
any district to do
any policy making we just
as with the gifted bill
would like district to share what they
have in place for a best practices
folder um
so i i honestly i
just i don't at all see or have the same
concerns about this creating an onerous
onerous
uh administrative requirement i i'm just
speaking how i look at the intent of the
bill
share with share what's already public
in the common folder so people can
review that the same same as gifted
representative
thanks
thanks very much mike um
so just um just a few points um i wanted
to to get at listening to what's been
made here and and uh and
i think um i think melissa made some
some very good points and observations
and and
with some very justifiable concerns with
respect to um
in classroom
audio and video streaming and and you
know the potential um
unintended consequences that could go
along with that
but i also wanted to to address another
comment
she made with respect to the new
hampshire school boards association
she mentioned it's a lobbying
organization lobbying certainly one of
their
things they have a govern government
affairs
aspect to it but in my experience being
on a school board
i really didn't see so much of their
their lobbying
or government affairs effort as i did
see their their best practices when
submitting when preparing
model policy development for school
boards and in hopkinton we would start
with with that and um and we would tune
it to be specific to our our district
but at least we had something that was a
good start very good solid starting
point uh based on
not just work here in new hampshire but
probably i'm assuming work in other
states uh as well so so um so i think
there's a lot to that organization and
um and i appreciate all the the work um
uh and experience and skill that they
that they bring to uh to school boards
um uh throughout the state
the um
um the
really the next thing i think and and
this is something that that that melissa
um was was very emphatic on um uh
and i and we've heard from the
department how how job one is student
safety
and uh and you know uh diana and the
commissioner speak about it all the time
you know student safety is an important
thing
and and
my concern
or a concern
about having a folder with with i won't
even call them best practices but
practices of each school district with
regards to um
um uh cla you know classroom uh audio
video
um uh and um and in classroom observers
uh would be now we've have we created
like a one-stop shop for anybody to just
go through and say hey you know what i'm
going to look at at all of these and see
which one just happens to say
that
that that
a a
a class
has to be delivered
both in person and remote and that
classroom observation uh is allowed
either way in person or remote and
doesn't necessarily limit it to uh to
any you know particular individual
uh such as a parent or a guardian or or
or or somebody but opens the door wide
open and so you know have we created a
one-stop shop for somebody to go oh
i see what's going on here
i could just go over to this school
district and
you know what if they don't let me in
then they're breaking their own board
policy and if they're breaking their own
board policy it's going to happen
exactly what representative tanner said
it's going to spark a lawsuit
because that's what policies are are
really there to to provide is a
consistent clear
um
a requirement independent of anybody's
sort of best thinking like maybe a
teachers or or principal building
principal or the superintendent um you
know best thinking given a certain
situation creates a black and white um
um policy that that um that that applies
independent of any any um knowledge of
what may be going on at the time um and
then i guess the the the third um uh
thing is before we sort of jump in to
creating the office of the file cabinet
the best practices file cabinet um you
know let's let's see what happens with
this this first folder with with the
gifted students i took a look at the
statute
and and it went into effect
uh july 23rd
it applies beginning to the
2022-2023 school year which is the
school year where
we'll will be in as of um
july 1st and it says by august 1st of
that year so
so this will be due this summer is when
um is when
uh school districts will uh shall submit
to the department of education no later
than august first an annual narrative
report detailing the policies programs
procedures that are um for gift for
gifted students so i i think we're we're
we're way too early to say it's making a
big difference or anything uh like that
at this point because
you know the the the
the the the due date for even putting
things into this folder hasn't even
hasn't even come yet and um and so uh
we don't know we don't know if it makes
a big difference we don't know how how
time um how much time is involved on the
part of the school district but
certainly some time uh is involved and
and i think
you know
let's i probably starting with with with
the bill with representative moffett's
bill from
from last year uh with respect to best
practices for gifted students you know
what maybe that's sort of a
good place to start to sort of root out
how effective this file cabinet is is
going to be
without potentially putting something in
there that is going to compromise
student safety or or create a channel
for somebody with with you know maybe
you know motivations that that are
inconsistent with with student safety um
because it wouldn't appear to me that
the gifted
folder would would have that type of um
you know
problem um with it so so you know i'm
i'm sort of thinking let's let's
let's see what happens with with with
what's already been done
and um
and um uh and then you know this could
be
you know uh looked at down the road but
uh but clearly i think we're we're
getting into a very
sensitive area districts may do things
differently depending upon the interests
of their local school boards
and um
um and i hate to see it be used for for
purposes that we're not going to improve
and further um you know um
student outcomes so thanks
yeah thank you representative luno and i
agree with your point about practices
versus best practices best practices is
kind of a term but i i think you're
right
practices uh what's a good practice for
some might not be seen as a good
practice for others
um
and i want to make one other comment and
then of course we're all it's a work
session but uh
diana attorney fenton is in the house
and i i i think some of us would like to
get a perspective from her i wanted to
make i'm going to say two things before
um
one of which um
to go back to the gifted bill as i've
we've said many times that's a model for
this approach
um
the
the five to two vote we did take a vote
on um gifted a couple terms ago
one of the two who voted against it you
know his public record was chairman lat
and um i just
had conversation after conversation with
rick about um the gifted bill
and and he's a smart guy and he knows a
lot of and he's flagging all these
questions what about this what about
that what about this or what are we
going to think about this kind of thing
but that uh on and on and on and he
finally
uh he unders understood
the intent is why he eventually
supported it
i said chairman i said rick
all these things that you're flagging
makes the point of the intent of the
bill these are things that need
discussion
we don't want to impose any
policy we just want to gather and gather
existing public information into one
spot for the convenience of those but
i hope and finally he
came around and understood that in the
process of
requiring this information to be
submitted and via again i i'll say i
don't think it was egregious just send
us what you have in place
but this districts in the schools that
don't didn't in the gifted case that
didn't have anything in place or that
don't have anything in place
out of that comes the conversation so
the same thing here representative
tanner uh as representative vlad did is
fl and you just now flagging all these
potential concerns and my answer to you
is what i
kept saying to to rick i said rick those
are all great questions but
you know
we're not asking we're not asking for
any policy we're just asking uh for what
you have for information and if any
districts aren't paying attention or
for whatever reason and through this
process
a gap is identified that needs attention
locally then that's up to the districts
to
have that local conversation and fill in
those gaps however they want to so
anyway and then the last point i wanted
to make was um
on this bill and also the bill this
afternoon um representative hobson and i
had uh stopped by deal we've
whenever that was we had a
chat with caitlin and the commissioner
came by just informally talking about um
some of the last year's legislation and
getting some some thought mckenzie was
there and
a guy named scott came by and we just
talked about um
some stuff that was on radar screens and
we asked them some questions and diana's
here and she can
hopefully provide a little bit of input
from doe
so
there was from that informal uh confab
um we got some notes and ideas as to uh
how
some of the folks at doe
looked at uh the gifted bill or um
the
classroom recording
issue
so anyway uh
these are things that we've been
discussing for a while it's it's nothing
that just you know popped up
uh other
anybody else before we ask
sure
thank you
i do completely agree with the safety
and security aspect 100
i do have to say though at this point in
time we've all been required to put
together our safety plans right there's
housed in central location at this point
in time i'm assuming homeland security
but they're housed in the central
location
my thought is just
now that we all have
a mini computer that we carry around
most kids do
right
yeah
no
yeah just the safety plans for homeland
sec homeland security i think that was
in a recent bill that we passed i don't
recall and maybe diana has this if those
are available for public inspection they
are not available for public inspection
but this wouldn't be available for
public inspection i thought the question
was just it would be in a centralized
location at doe correct this is
available for public inspection
okay that sorry that wasn't my
interpretation unless it unless it
clearly
um states that it is not um
a 91a maybe that's something
that we could do
um i'm just wondering now i guess my
point is we all have devices schools are
at this point requiring devices if not
even assigning them even to elementary
kids that go remote did go remote or
even to utilize i'm just wondering if
it's time that we need to consider some
type of high-level broad framework jim
saying i know that the big saying is to
kick the can isn't it time that we
address video recordings it's it's so
widespread at this point in time just
because it's year 2022. so i'm not
districts
i believe school districts are if
they're going to
have
have any sort of video surveillance on
school property that they have to have a
policy and they have to hold a public
hearing as as you mentioned uh prior to
that i i
i don't think that districts can just
set up cameras and
move on
i guess i just don't understand why is
it an issue if we house this information
at doe in the central location we just
we ran into this even with the saus and
how they're set up we have local control
which we pride ourselves on but we're
scattered we have so many different
things happening i just don't understand
why we don't try to centralize that and
maybe come up with best practices as you
mentioned i i'm
not trying to be argumentative i'm truly
trying to grasp this and understand why
it's not a good thing that's all
thank you and thank you uh
representative hall just a quick
question so a school district could put
in their report we don't do anything for
gifted and talented or we don't have any
policy and that's the report year after
year they can put that report in and and
we're making an assumption that that
school district is going to say whoa all
these other school districts have
something maybe we need to look at
something is that what the intent is
sure uh in fact uh the link that
represents robertson shared with me when
they saw what d.o.e put out is a
technical advisory they said with regard
to gifted if you have no policies in
place
just tell us that so
if districts don't have policies in
place and don't want to have policies in
place that's up to the district
so um but again as i said before the
intent of that bill and this bill is to
encourage uh through statute um
districts locally to identify gaps and
maybe talk about them
and if they in the gifted case if if the
district never puts anything into place
they that's okay you know the intent is
not to mandate anything it's just to
get it on the radar screens because
there's some things like the gifted
things why it's law and why we're having
this discussion here there are
some districts
have some things in place and some don't
so out of this with no mandate no
spending requirement
the vision is that these gaps will end
up being filled which otherwise would
not be had we not shined a light or
had had this uh discussion in this
potential statute represent
i don't know if this question is for you
or for attorney fenton
but i went just went to the doe
to the
advisory the technical advisory
and
um
it has a survey that the department of
education made for people to fill out
and it's part of this ess system um
survey page of the css system
and
when i went to look at the survey
i couldn't get into the survey
okay so i have no idea
what questions are being asked or why
they're being asked from the state
department of education
and i guess
my whole thing about
centralized data is
why
do you need centralized data and
who
or whom is going to be using that data
and for what purpose are they going to
use that data i mean if
all you wanted was to have school
districts have a discussion
all the doe would have to do would be to
put out their own
uh notice that says
you know um
we think that it would be important for
you to develop
um
video
surveillance and video uh whatever
you've done with your zoom classes um
to to uh
address that subject the same thing with
gifted and talented all they had to do
was to send out a notice to the schools
that say
you know we're discussing gifted and
talented and
we think you need a discussion on the
local level
why do they
why do they need a central database
where they're collecting more
information about schools and students
at the doe
that that's one of my and also
who's developing the surveys and what do
the surveys look like because the way
the surveys are are worded could make a
um you know significant difference on
how how the date is collected
um
i just think that it's um
you know the the
the risk is at the local level and um a
few years ago we passed a bill i believe
representative cordelli was the sponsor
of it
that said that um any internet
connection from schools
uh had to agree to a total privacy
policy
and
um
it hamstrung a lot of of
new ideas innovative things that were
going on in schools for example um i
know at one of the schools that i was
talking to they had a drafting online
drafting
that they no longer could use as long as
that bill
was in effect and that's the kind of
thing where
again speaking as a former teacher that
that had to put up with all the
regulations and had jumped through all
the hoops
and realizing that the charter schools
don't have to do anything
any of those hoops unless it's
specifically stated in the bill
that if it's good for the goose it
should be good for the gander that we
shouldn't be putting
more regulations more requirements
more time
if if it's just
collecting data
if we don't know why it's collected we
don't know
you know if it's to spark a discussion
just ask them to have a discussion if if
there's some purpose of collecting the
data
and having it in a central location and
it's never seen by anybody or never used
by anybody
what's the deal here it's it's a
it's a non
it's a no deal you know so those are the
questions i want one answered um and
again i'll just say time is money
sure thank you representative tana and
you mentioned regulations and i say
again uh this bill uh this proposed
measure uh has no regulations other than
a reporting requirement to let us know
what you already have
i'm sorry
that's a requirement that's a regulation
okay that's that's why we're putting it
into statute is that yes
okay
yes a reporting requirement ioc is a
regulation i guess it's semantics uh
i don't want more i don't want more we
don't want more regulations if we can
avoid that uh we just want to uh have
people share public information the
cordelia bill i i heard about when this
first came up uh chairman ladd uh
mentioned that the you know the cornell
cordelia bill and all the trouble that
you mentioned came out of that and
that's what speaking for myself i don't
want that corneli bell i don't want
that
that flowed out of that that's what
that's what this is about and finally
uh the point about
doe or the state school board or whoever
putting a memo out and asking for the
same information that's come up before
and my answer to that that's a fair
question you know why do we need a
statute and my answer is
the impermitor of
uh statute the fact that the people's
representatives thought that something
was important enough to have a hear a
hearing an exact session discussion and
uh about a law
that has some gravitas and that matters
um not everybody loves the state school
board people not everybody loves the
commissioner believe it or not and if if
the commissioner sends out and he said
this uh
you know
and diana can can
in a moment or to uh
speak to a lot of this
uh
the notion of having this accomplished
by a memo
doesn't cut it and didn't cut it and
wouldn't cut it a lot of schools just
are not responsive to memos from
the doe but they have to be responsive
if this isn't statute gifted is now in
statute and people know that
and so locally uh now people can come to
their superintendent of the school board
and say uh there's a lot that says you
need to submit a report as to what you
do
for gifted uh are you following the law
so that's the wrong answer but i think
statute matters much more than the memo
that's why you know we were looking
using the statutory route rather than a
memo
all right so so we've got um
what eight of us around here we've spent
almost an hour an hour and 15 minutes um
on this on top of what's already been
invested what's the plan here
but before i answer what's the plan
representative
putting something into a law
um
whether it's a requirement or a
regulation is this in my
my
view is the same thing you don't you
don't come down with a heavy hand of a
law if what you're trying to what your
intent truly is is just to have a
discussion
okay if that's what the intent is
then
you don't need a law you need a
memorandum and you need people to
actually at the state department who
have specialties in this area for
example the bureau of education
opportunities
to go around the schools and say look
this is what
a great gifted and talented program
looks like this is what a great
policy and you should have a policy i'm
sure that the insurance companies primex
and those insurance companies that uh
ensure schools
um have
talked to them extensively
about the risks of of videotaping and
that sort of thing and and
uh student privacy um
i'm i'm almost positive um
and and this just seems like an
intrusion a heavy government intrusion
into something that should be local
discussion
and if you're again if your intent is
just a discussion then a memorandum um
should do it and certainly uh
information coming out i know when they
used to have
like
um you know a social studies coordinator
or guidance coordinator at the
department of education that person and
that that particular department used to
give out information to local schools
and and people that were teaching or
people that were guidance counselors
about best practices what's going on
what's really needed
um and that in itself would spark
um discussion
um you know so
i just think this is a heavy hand i
think it's it's a big government
idea i think it's i think it's um a
database
that's going nowhere unless we can find
out
who actually
is using the data why they're using the
data and have a copy of the survey
that's going out
thank you
uh website hudson
thank you for taking my question and rep
tanner i love all your comments
first question is
charter schools since charter schools
are public schools would this apply to
them as well
and second
i would love to hear from the doe it
does not apply nothing applies to
charter schools unless in the in the
specific
um
law
that it says it applies to charter
schools other than that they don't have
to apply it to it
thank you representative hobson and
representative tanner
before i ask d.o.e to to
be available for questions
to uh
to represent luno's point about where
we're gonna go this um i wanna let dear
we have a chance to weigh in and um
and then
to dave's question uh i've got a bunch
of notes here so what i kind of
anticipate is just
um like the charter school issue that
just came up i mean these are things
that
in the
next year if something like this is
introduced
uh
i think the
language i think
should address better
uh questions that have been raised today
like charter schools so that's kind of
a quick answer to you but before i ask
representative uh not representative or
colonel or commissioner uh
uh
excellency uh
attorney fenton um she's she's on her
way up it's okay it's happening
references to me
it's still technically morning good
morning diana fenton from the department
of representative tanner the survey
questions are in your email
they were written by nate green who's
testified before this committee and so i
just sent that email to you if you have
sure send it to
yeah of course um
i'm happy to answer any questions that
the committee might have it's nice to
see everyone again
sure i don't even know if i'm
technically on this group um because i
just showed up accidentally early so
anyway i can beat representative saudi
um can you tell can you tell me what the
doe um would think about with a measure
like this
what what would it entail
um
i'm thinking you know if someone wanted
to
you know my constituents
particularly wanted to know what were we
doing with classroom recordings or you
know
parent observations
housing something like this what would
that entail for you
or for the doe
have you thought about this you answers
to some of our questions
uh
yeah to some of them i mean i think the
we always take our
guidance from the law as written right
and then we
we base it on that and we base it on our
prior precedence of interpreting similar
laws and so i think
it would be reasonable to interpret it
similar to the gifted and talented
structure and there was a lot of
discussion about that a couple of
legislative sessions ago
in terms of what would this look like um
i believe that i testified that you know
our concern was that it would be a file
cabinet that would just sit there and so
the idea was it would become a website
it would be more interactive and that's
how we have designed this um i think
representative luna's point is
is correct we just don't know
how often this tool will be used we just
don't have that information right now
this has just been launched um but we
had all those concerns that we've heard
this morning with the gifted and
talented bill just in terms of how much
would this be utilized and accessed and
um
and how much of doe times and staff
would be put into it and so we have been
able to fulfill
the the requirements of that law i think
pretty easily
and
create this website and we will see how
often that is utilized
i would like to address representative
luna's points um
i off the top of my head i'm not sure
which law talks about surveillance in in
the school setting
i know that it is addressed
i would be surprised and this is just my
own observation i would be surprised if
schools don't have a policy some sort of
policy on
surveillance issues
when it comes to school safety issues in
terms of
the homeland security concern which was
brought up
that law has been on the books for quite
some time it was amended last session
more editorial rather than substantive
and schools do have to turn in those
blueprints to homeland security i
believe that doe gets a copy of them as
well but we've made it clear in our
testimony and in the law that we are not
first responders and we should not be
looked at to have that information
available in a crisis and we have put
there's a provision in the law which
excludes those blueprints from public
consumption those are just private
internal documents
if there was a concern about school
safety which i certainly heard from
representative luna i think you could
tailor it
similar to the blueprints
that it is internal consumption only i
don't know what that would look like to
limit it only to the districts right now
our website is open to the public as you
all know um but that is
potentially a way that we could address
those concerns because i think they're
very valid concerns
any other
questions
of course
[Laughter]
i am remiss that i did not bring my my
law book
um well hopefully we have those in the
future um this does not apply to charter
schools as it as it is written now um i
had an amendment uh which was uh
defeated
um
that would extend it to charter schools
so as far as you know
this isn't uh as it's written right now
doesn't apply to charters or
v-lacs is that true so i don't have the
language of the statute in front of me i
was looking at the ta
so
just based on that i don't believe that
this is applicable to charter schools
but i can double check and get back to
you but your understanding of the law is
correct the charter school law makes
very clear it has to be explicitly
stated that any new law passed is
applicable to charter schools
and and prenda and kai and
the other uh private agencies that are
doing these internet um
classrooms and
all that they
at this point are not submitting any
um
any of this uh video or zoom
or what they do with their recordings or
how the video is done or anything like
that
that you know not to my knowledge
and and they wouldn't necessarily be
under the
statute as written right now unless
expressly stated
correct unless expressly stated but i
also think it's important to look at the
timeline this this particular law the
gifted and talented bill
had been
worked on quite a bit and it was passed
i think in the in the
session when we're all remote due to the
pandemic and now it's become effective
and so i think some of the programs that
you have mentioned were on that same
timeline
so as that bill was passed it would not
necessarily have been thought of to
incorporate
efas and and prenda because they were
all on a similar timeline that's just
based on my recollection
and so it's just important to look at
when different things were passed and
could you just speak a little bit to the
difference between if all you want is a
discussion
uh sending out a memorandum rather than
making a law
could you
i think i know what you're asking about
but could you clarify that a little bit
sure so if our intent in having this
bill and also the gifted and talented
bill
is simply to
encourage discussion
within schools about it
something that we feel is important
do you feel
what is the
discrepancy between just putting out a
memorandum to that
instance and providing information
to schools and encouraging schools
versus putting something in the statutes
i think in its simplest form one is a
mandate and one is a suggestion
so this is a mandate or regulation in
a loose
uh rather than just a requirement
i think you've already answered that
question but yes i mean if
obviously the department can put out a
request
issue a technical advisory and request
that this information be submitted and
in large part i think districts are very
responsive um
i think the department has very good
working relationships with with
districts
however
if the legislature passes a bill which
makes it a requirement
then there will be
uh not only will that be messaged to the
districts that this is now a requirement
but logically there will be required
follow-up by the department to reach out
to districts that might not have
submitted those documents and and that i
think is an important consideration for
this legislative body is that and that's
across the board not just talking about
this particular bill but any requirement
whether data any kind of data collection
um the department does spend uh
time i can't quantify how much just
doing that follow-up and reaching out to
districts and reminding them to to
submit
one thing that jumps to the top of my
head is the restraint and seclusion
report every year 126u
that is a requirement every november the
department produces a report that looks
at the restraint seclusion numbers from
all the districts i know you're going to
ask about charter schools and yes i
think they are included in them
and that report is turned over to the
legislature but i can tell you from
personal experience we do have to every
year spend time
reaching out to certain districts which
have not submitted for whatever reason
it's
not their fault just other things come
up um so i think that's just important
to keep in mind this is always going to
be that
uh
staff necessity as i call it
for
for the follow-up and that would be
different than if it was just
a request
so if i was if i was a
concerned parent or maybe not even a
parent just a concerned citizen in a
school district
um
that will that data be available to me
can i file a 91a on that
or whatever it is called where they have
to release
data can
specific to my school district
so in general information that is on our
website is for public consumption and so
if you file a right to know and the
information is available so for example
the
gifted and talented information is my
understanding is
publicly available or
accessible
um it would be right there
the 91a would be early
we had mentioned the blueprints the
emergency safety plans those are not to
be released
this legislative body could
in theory craft something so that the
information you are discussing
surveillance recording things of that
nature
is not to be released
um and just one last question uh so you
say that the this
there is staff time
taken to follow up on the staff time to
accumulate them um and i've been
hammering about how time is money on the
school side of it but time is money at
the state department of education's um
side of it as well
and
so
one of the things that we often
we've heard in the past is that the
department of education
is short staffed or you know that that
you're overburdened and i'm just
wondering if if this is one more burden
for this for the department of education
well that's a bit of a tricky question
the department
um
one of our many roles is to be
responsive to the legislation that is
passed
and
if the legislature feels that this is an
important
measure to bring forward the department
will be responsive to it does it take up
does it require staff time yes it does
um
but this is not the only measure that
would require staff time to create and
implement and and follow up on as i
mentioned the the restraints occlusion
reports as well so
um that's not a consideration that the
department
does in its analysis because we are
responsive to the laws that are passed
so i think that is more i'm going to
defer that back to this legislative body
to to make that recommendation and the
department will respond in
as appropriate
thank you attorney i know it's known and
you indicated at noon noontime but
i'm what i'm hearing from you though is
that the response to a memo oftentimes
is not what you'd like it to be is that
fair to say
i i don't think you get the consistency
there's no way to ensure that you will
get the consistency the request goes out
and
i don't know how much the department
would
invest in doing that follow-up we
the interpretation by the department
would be different
if it was a shall do this rather than a
you know
may send out
a ta requesting this information i think
the response from the department would
be um
different yes
cross-examination and assessment the
right term uh
just a quick question so i just want to
be clear that the doe's role
is solely
clerical
period
the doe is not going to look at these
policies to say whoa look what this
one's got and what it's solely to throw
them into a folder online that's it
and maybe
track the data track who's visiting that
who's opening that folder because i
think that that's really important to
know
but i'm going to answer your question
globally and then i will kind of drill
down okay to to your question um
one of the overarching concerns not just
on this legislation but all the
legislation uh every session the
question from the department's
perspective is always what is the
expectation
of the department what is the
requirement of the department because
historically what we have seen our bills
are passed and then we fast forward two
three four five years and then someone
says yeah what has the department done
with with this law what has the
department done was with this
information and there have been times
where i have sat before you and said
very coherently with my law degree uh i
don't know or my other favorite uh
nothing
and that is just a reality we've all
seen that
and so when the gifted and talented bill
came up i remember having conversations
with representative moffat to say
what is the expectation on the
department because we can collect
any document this legislature wants us
to collect but in terms of being good
stewards of state dollars state time
state resources what is the end result
what is the expectation that the
department will do so to drill down to
your question
we will read these policies we're not
just
blindly putting them in there but we are
not in a position to weigh in on them
and to say
oh this is good policy
this doesn't seem like a good policy you
wouldn't do that kind of analysis
the objective of the law has passed the
gifted and talented bill was to have it
be a warehouse if you will um where
people can go and and look for best
practices that was the understanding
from the department's perspective and
that is what was then created
so
yes the department will likely look at
them and read them just to see what's
being submitted
but we're not going and doing any
analysis or saying hey this we're going
to send this out as a best practice or
we really think that i'll pick on my old
high school kenneth high school has a
really good policy we're going to send
this out and be preemptive and say
everyone should adopt this policy
we have always deferred to local control
and the idea was this is something that
depart districts can reach out and look
at and make that their own determination
and i don't think there was ever any
intent that the department would weigh
in and have that say
good question representing the fall and
a good answer i i think
uh
last carl i know it's a little bit
afternoon um for
um
attorney fenton
thank you so much for being here we have
another session this afternoon you might
be around for that
look i'm going to try
uh since i'm already late for my noon
why not
all right thank you for your time i will
actually get to you i i was bloviating
i'm sure that slowly cleansed up uh okay
uh russell roano would ask about the
purposes so uh really where we go from
here
what what i look and looking to do i
have a lot of notes and questions from
you all what i'll try to do there's a
form here to fill out i started at
subcommittee work session um what i will
do is tonight or sometime soon i'll
organize my notes and i'll send it to
all of you uh here so you can see some
of the points that i had and then i
would encourage you to
add or edit or feel free to just uh
add on any anything that
my notes might have missed that you
think is saline or relevant or should be
part of a little report from our work
session
um
i don't
i don't necessarily see a need to try to
squeeze in another meeting before july
or necessarily even in september
we had a hearing an exec session we
talked a lot today about concerns and
aspects of this
does anybody want to try to have another
session
i'm seeing representative cornell
shaking her head in the negative
i'm kind of there too uh but i i don't
want to
so okay so what i'll do dave is i'll uh
work some notes up them with you all you
can
edit add whatever and then once we all
have everything on there that we think
should be included i'll send it to the
chair and the whole committee and um
and then this uh
as far as a recommendation i guess uh
i'll put this
in my notes um if this were to come back
in a future session uh here are the
concerns
and the pieces of it that we've
identified that need to be worded better
or differently if if this ever comes
back
so um is the um is the interim study
committee going to take a a vote on a
recommendation
good question i don't have a motion to
make other than what i just said um i
want to i'd make a motion to well i
can't make a motion because i'm not on
the committee
i would like to make a motion that that
uh
the vote um
we
yeah not recommended this for
future legislation
okay uh
as to that motion i'm reticent to have a
vote on this because
uh several of the people that the chair
assigned to be here uh could not be here
representative lekkis was assigned and
she's out of state representative saudi
was assigned so to be fair to those
folks who were assigned to the committee
and weren't able to be here uh i i don't
want to you know disenfranchise them um
or we could schedule another meeting
right correct
uh
and my feeling and we can you know we we
would have if we have another meeting
that could involve them would need to be
in july it's that's kind of
i'm sorry i meant to say joan i meant to
say june and i we're kind of running out
of time we could try to do that or we
could try to do something in september
so i don't see us having a vote um
for the reasons i just gave
so again what i will do as i said is
i'll organize the notes from this first
work session send it to everybody for
your review
and then um
we can meet again in september
uh if uh
if the chair recommends that
and we don't have to make a
recommendation does it
sure excuse me doesn't in the past when
i've been on these interim study
committees that we usually
have a vote have a have a statement
that's given to the full committee then
the full committee meets in september
and just goes through them
after that they received the report and
make the final decision from there
that's our vote
right our vote
sure i mean that's what happened with
the gifted bill originally as as i said
a couple times also the unified sports
uh
so
i
guess
what will happen is as i said i'll
organize the notes from this session
send them to the chair with the
recommendation that uh
we meet in september and then at a
subsequent meeting try to have a motion
at that time so so and you know
the this committee has a lot of interim
study bills
a lot
and and there's going to be i think a
number of full committee
interim study meetings in september and
i think rick has sort of reserved
september for that plus we have to wrap
up in september i think
um with the with the full committee
vote on
the uh on these i don't see
is
since a vote today would not be binding
on the committee i i think we know how
the vote would would would land
given who's here today and is on the
committee
but it doesn't really matter but at
least as far as as far as our interim
study concluding its work
um
rather than scheduling another
meeting in a month where there's going
to be a lot of meetings um i think we
just go ahead and complete it today
and um
and then we've got another meeting this
afternoon
in 45 minutes uh sure representative
blissfield
thank you i hear absolutely hear what
were saying just for me i tried to
research a little bit ahead of time but
it was important to me to hear what
everyone had to say and digest all of it
i personally would like to take it back
to
my school district and bounce it off of
some of them i'm not ready to take a
vote i'm ready to dive in and do some
more research and then
make a vote
if you're all willing in september i
personally just need more time
thank you blitzfield uh that's the way
that i'm leading as i've already said uh
we'll send a
summary to the chair and then
have a discussion with him and uh
and probably
we'll need to do this the right way we
need to come back as representative
tanner said and have a vote with with
all the members here in september
representative cornell i i think it will
be hard to have
a vote with the people who weren't here
for this entire discussion to have them
voting on they didn't hear any of the
this discussion or no and i and i think
it's okay to have subs on subcommittees
and i think representatives hopson and
ford are the two people that are here in
place of
representative lekkes and and saudi so
i think we could have a vote
yeah thank you
i just would not feel right about having
a vote uh involving
folks that the chair did did not have in
the committee i love that dave's here
and that deb sarah that all of us here
but i i would not feel right about
having a vote
without everybody
and i don't think it's my call to let
uh them vote while i'm glad they're here
so again i'm going to recommend to the
chair that uh if he
wants us to
make a recommendation uh that he then he
can ask the the people that he's
assigned to the committee to come back
in september and if he wants to reassign
anybody or expand the committee uh
he's done that before i could do that
again so that's that's where i'm at i'll
make a report
that you all will look at ahead of time
send it to the chair and then let him
make a recommendation as
a september meeting
and a vote or not
can we ask that those that were absent
review the youtube and so that they know
exactly what we were talking about don't
have the epp excellent point
representative cornell
that's an excellent point in this
technologies there so somebody mentioned
the concern that they weren't here well
uh
to the whole point of this bill and
being on youtube forever they can review
this and then they'll be read in
so does that sound like an approach that
works
all right with the report send it to the
chair he can have this meet in september
if he wants and then uh we can have a
vote um at that time
what time we're gonna start the next uh
schedule for one p.m
uh
i guess the chair can push it back
you can't move in this i i wish i could
have told diana so she didn't have to
yeah uh what
do you have diana's okay uh so 115.
all right we'll see see then thank you
for being here thank you so much
let's uh
get started here if we could um
representative ellison is here
representative uh
i'm just looking at the roster epson
hollis here represent luna is here
representative hobson is here
representative litzfield is here from
office the owner from the assign
committee who's not here is
representative lekkas
and we have uh some other visitors here
welcome back representative ford and uh
represent tanner is is back as well
so uh to get right to it and i think i
did check uh the youtube recording did
is out there
so i forgotten that that was gonna
happen so uh but represent cornell made
a good point that the there were at
least two from the previous subcommittee
who weren't here they can watch it and
uh come back to that other
bill
um at their
convenience all right so this one this
afternoon work session uh interim study
work session on hb 1676 which has an fn
it's maybe the shortest bill
one of the shortest bills you you'll
ever see
and it simply calls for
creating an incentive grant capability
to
reward school districts that improve
their standardized test scores and
that's the the that's it
um so
real quick uh this also we had a hearing
an exec session on it one of the things
that came up and i mentioned this in a
in an email that i put out
one of the concerns that representative
mary beth wallace flagged was
the initial language in the
measure
called for a transfer from the so-called
rainy day fund
to doe
to create a an account and then
establish a criteria
to reward schools that
improve their standardized test scores
so one of the issues was was that the
right way to do it if we do it and if we
did do it should there be a separate
line item so i'm going to kind of leave
it at that and uh
i'm just we're interested in
some perspectives on on
this proposed measure
representative
uh thank you chair just being relatively
new to the process the outcome of a
study committee usually is
we recommend it's pass it does not pass
it passes with amendments
what does that usually look like
sure thanks for the question i've done a
number of these i'm sure others have as
well uh
typically yes uh the work said you'll
have a work session or multiple work
sessions and eventually
the subcommittee will
take a vote on a measure
to
i think the choices in this case are to
recommend otp
or itl and i i believe it may be
representative
uh i know if an option is to recommend a
version of otpa in other words
uh
for example from what i just said if
there's a motion to support this
measure if it was amended so that the
funding did was a separate line item as
opposed to coming from the rainy day
fund so i think there's an otp
otpa option as well that could be
recommended to the full committee that
if you probably yeah
so thanks mike i think that would
actually be
inside of the uh the committee report so
there's that what we'll do
what the committee will do eventually is
vote on on the the two motions would be
recommended for of
future legislation or not recommended
for future legislation and there would
also be a very short committee report
two or three sentences and that's where
you could put uh you know if it was
recommended for future to include
you know such and such changes so yeah
so i guess there's three options
basically is the uh representative
explained there is a kind of an otp
otpa option future or not it's either
recommended or not
okay
okay uh and representative ford you know
well you're very quiet this morning if
you want to sound off i mean it's a work
session so insane representation is not
on this was not assigned to this but
again
attorney fenton is back and uh
may have some input as well or have a
chance to answer some questions
so um
i i spoke a lot this morning try not to
speak as much so i have a few thoughts
on this but i um
you know who else who
wants to uh offer some thoughts on this
1676 representative hall
i just had a question about does anyone
know and maybe that's attorney fenton
back when we you know schools for city
schools i mean do we have all of that
data like when schools of neighbor
improvement and they they were targeted
to be those city schools and they had to
come up with their i think it might have
been another one whether those sips
school improvement plans and all that
just do we have that data
as to where they came and
they came and went you know what i mean
like was it successful or
circles improve their standardized
scores or
attorneys attorney to kind of speed
things along this afternoon can i invite
you to come up to the uh to the
microphone and and
as these questions come up rather than
save you for the end like
i don't want to say dessert but uh it's
maybe we can
get you involved right quick here to
keep things moving
and did you hear up to the false
question
she might restate maybe sure
back a few years ago we had the you know
schools are targeted according to their
test scores and they were identified as
city schools
and they had to come up with you know
schools in need of improvement and then
they were they had sip plans the school
improvement plans and at some point it
was decided that every school was going
to be a school in need of improvement
because of their scores and whatnot so
what happened to that
um
do we know because it's kind of the same
thing it was an incentive to bring your
test scores up
do we know what ever happened or did it
just fall apart because it wasn't
working or
what
thank you for the question for the
record diana fenton uh with the
department of education i i don't know
off the top of my head as the short
answer i can i can look into that but
i'm not aware of that program um
i i don't think anything necessarily
fell apart but there might have been a
time span in which that program was run
and then
there's no additional follow-up that's
typically and again i'm not speaking
directly to the program you mentioned
but that's typically what we've seen
historically so but i can certainly look
into that
thank you
that maybe he's a prime sponsor i should
offer just a few words on this
to
provide a little bit of fidelity or
whatever
so the the impetus behind this and you
know most all of you were at the hearing
when this first came up as every bill
does and we talked about this summit
exec session and it was recommended for
interim study
uh the thinking behind this again is a
prime sponsor among several sponsors
is that
i and we
saw and see some utility and some value
to
rewarding
schools that
improve
and is and we spend so much time on
school funding
and right now
as you all know so well
there are mechanisms in place to
help schools for example with low third
grade reading scores
now the concern i'm sure you've all
heard this before
to some folks it that is a
a disincentive of sorts at least in some
people's minds in other words the worse
they do the worse the third graders are
reading the more money they get
and say the intent of that is to
identify schools that are struggling and
give them money the assumption being
that they the money will help you
improve their instruction which
is different uh perspectives on how
effective that is
uh so the thinking here is
uh and i i hate to say reward reward
failure that's i'm not i don't want to
use that term some others have used that
term in term with regard to
uh
giving money to districts whose third
grade scores are low
again as i just said i understand the
intent of that
but there's also a mindset that if
we can somehow
give
districts incentives to
uh
apply some approaches that maybe have
been proven effective elsewhere
that there may be some utility to that
now going back to the hearing um
it came up about uh
competition and
this is not
this as we say as the sponsors see it
this does not involve competing against
any other school all this involves is
proposed
is
competing
so to speak against a baseline
against a school's
establish whatever baseline is
established in terms of whatever
assessment is used now i
have to as i said earlier this morning
some of us spoke informally with some
folks at d.o.e about the general concept
of this and there was some interest in
that
uh
the question
if this moves forward at some point we
come back to it next year
uh what assessment should be used and
katelyn davis had some ideas though we
did not in the initial
proposal
specifically identify any assessment yet
but
with this to move forward
uh one vision is that
doe would have
the
authority to
work with stakeholders to identify the
best assessment and then the criteria
for for rewards
so there's a little bit more background
on the thinking behind this and again
wanting to reward achievement
as opposed to simply also rewarding
if rewarding is the right word
you know giving money to schools that
have established uh
low scores
so
there's a little bit more background
representative luna
thank you very much mike um a couple
things i just want to want to point out
first of all i think in the um
in the
the research and uh report that was
prepared by the commission to study
school funding we
actually
went away from
the
third grade reading
characteristic and and instead focused
on true student characteristics and
district characteristics when when
looking at how to properly fund schools
so we looked at free and reduced priced
lunch as a proxy for
for
economic
factors family factors english language
learners special education and district
school district size
and so um so a a formula was developed
around these factors to um
to basically connect with a a predicted
uh cost for a school district to educate
all of its students to a statewide
outcome
using data that the doe has collected
for the last decade so so i agree with
you that the third grade reading i think
there's there's there's certainly
rationale for not using that as a
as a
performance factor in in
in determining funding but actually
using using
real
[Music]
predicted costs on what it would take
for a school district to educate its
students to a
to a
a statewide average
the um the second thing i wanted to um
sort of just note from the um the the
bill as as introduced is that uh there's
a you know it's a million dollar
appropriation with a fifty thousand
dollar cap per school district
and i think fifty thousand dollars you
know in a district like pittsfield uh
might mean a lot more than say fifty
thousand dollars in a district like
manchester and nashua
and um and so where we're looking to um
to do something as as an incentive
um
you know i'm i'm i'm not sure it's
necessarily a fair reward
um given the the
sort of disparate sizes we have you know
across the state in in school districts
uh
the uh and then i guess the other thing
from uh from a school funding
perspective
um uh first of all you know a million
dollars on a on a on a on a just short
of 1.1 billion dollars state
state
spend a 3 billion total spend isn't
really going to move the needle much for
for anybody and um and certainly in a in
a district like like let's say a small
district it uh it might be able to help
pay for
you know a 0.5 fte um you know social
work or something like that or or school
counselor but in a uh you know in a
larger district like manchester nashua
concord um it's it's not going to do
much in terms of
in terms of
what the district can can do with with
those funds so those those are really my
comments on the on the bill
yeah thank you representative
um and if you don't have the bill he's
you can find that in life you don't have
a copyright in front of you there was a
cap in the original measure uh of 50 000
and um
and i think that's a fair comment in the
sense that in the grand scheme of things
how much is 50 000 as you say pittsfield
it would mean more than a larger school
so the numbers is just me talking the
numbers can be tweaked if some version
of this ever moves forward i hope it
does i believe i believe in it i believe
in incentives and rewarding success in
some fashion however it may or may not
ever happen
um but you know
50 000 or
if we double it to
2 million or 100 000
um
it helps and and i know
school funding has been something that
you've especially been concerned about
and i think everyone my responsibility
every little bit helps but beyond that
um
if a school
improved their
assessment score whatever the assessment
may be how whatever the criteria may be
whatever the amount may be
psychologically
uh any school that won an award whether
it's 50 000 or
any amount
is a cost for celebration i think that
uh
in terms of morale
and public support and parental support
and school pride
any school that
earned an award
i think there's an intrinsic value to
that beyond just the monetary value i
think that if
winning an award increased parental
support for the local school
as i said uh school pride i think
there's value to that um you know
intrinsic value beyond just the monetary
value
uh
other thoughts
um uh rep who was first i
all right representative fred please you
go
my question was
actually is there any specific
designation of an award what is the
award given to accomplish
i assume it means i'm
simply assuming that if you did well at
that you're going to do more of it and
improve it more
i don't know but was there ever a
specific specific objective
for the award to be utilized to achieve
sure remember thank you as a prime
sponsor i'll try to answer that yeah the
objective is to
incentivize and reward and shine a light
on success
and
supplement supplementary to that
if a school
improved whatever assessment scores
we're talking about
uh
i think that could potentially this
isn't in the language but this is in the
thinking if the school improve their
scores and some people might look at
that school and say okay what did you do
different
uh how did you improve your scores is
that
something that we in a different
district could look at or consider
that's
that's another piece of this it's not
stated
beyond simply
rewarding success
and representative litchfield sure
thank you
so my impression of the bill initially
was incentive um in the form of maybe a
bonus as you mentioned
it's a one-time payment so i personally
don't look at it as something where you
could hire more staff because then
that's something that you're going to
have to fund in the future and that's
going to cost money to the taxpayers
the other concern i have going back to
this is not about school funding is i
feel as though we continue to look at
school funding from the standpoint of
those that are on reduced lunch those
english as a second language
what about the communities that are
predominantly middle class i feel as
though we continue to kind of saddle
financial burdens on them because we say
they can handle it and somehow they make
it happen
but it doesn't mean that it's easy
my thought is i don't understand why we
don't give incentive and it just simply
be a reward
why couldn't it be something
extracurricular that they purchased why
couldn't it be um it would be very small
because i don't you know like under
equipment is expensive but why couldn't
they put it to something like that i
just feel as though we always have the
rules and the strings you did a great
job here you go you do what you see fit
maybe it's air conditioners for the
classrooms just you do what you do
thank you for watching again as a
private sponsor i'll try to try to
respond to that
um
the intent of the sponsors is to
reward achievement and just give the
reward
out the award and the reward to the
district to do whatever they want to
whatever they want with with absolutely
uh
no or minimal strings of tests if they
want to i mean they
that's in local control if the district
qualifies for award then they get the
award and they decide what to do with it
that's my vision of it as a sponsor does
that answer your question a little bit
representative olson uh thank you uh
just to kind of to generally look at
this
uh
i i i'm against the bill as it's written
uh i i'm not in favor of having the
department of education determine what
sort of formula would be used even in
conjunction with other people
i've been pretty consistent on this
committee with
funding bills for for education
and wanting to know who's going to get
money when it goes through if it's
approved this is one where we don't know
and it would have the potential
of
sending grants to wolfeboro rye hanover
waterville valley
because that's the way it came out when
they ran the ran the data and
i'd be much happier if it came out
pittsfield claremont berlin and franklin
uh
i think we need to be very very careful
in using the wording that i've heard
today that we would be rewarding those
schools that have low scores
that is a disservice to school districts
with the disservice to students the
service to teachers in a number of
school districts in this state
uh so i i
until i can see hard data which is based
on what you've said miss mr chairman's
down the road because that hasn't been
developed uh i would not be in favor of
removing this piece of legislation
sure the the criteria that's a very fair
question this came up uh earlier in the
hearing and exec session what would the
criteria be one of the notes that i took
from the earlier discussion in this
measure
uh had to do with who would determine
the criteria
and the cr the cr should some version of
this move forward somehow someday
uh that's a great question and
my is a one of the early sponsors
i hear that and i agree with that
concern
uh
i want to be careful about trying to put
too much in the statute in terms of who
the stakeholders are
that would
work with doe to establish a criteria
that
works
you know the school board association
the municipal association the uh
school administrators
you know who who should
be involved with that and if
in my thinking is if you get too
prescriptive trying to stat in statute
uh
say who's going to help determine the
criteria to me it's a it's a little
cleaner and simpler if this
were to move forward in some fashion
to
trust doe and give them a fund and say
we trust that you will communicate with
stakeholders and you'll develop the
criteria you know here's an account and
here's some some funds for you to
reward success with according to a
criteria that we trust you to develop i
don't know how else to put that
but that's a kind of a short answer
representative tanner
um
yeah i've talked in the past about the
intrinsic value of
of awards that that schools and teachers
now get
and
there is a whole setup to reward
teacher the teacher of the year and
runners up in in new hampshire as well
as award the top elementary middle and
high schools and their runners-up
and it's a it's a fair system where
there are people on
on the committee that represent various
parts um and it's not necessarily tied
to a government
uh department um
i think that if the rewards monetary
rewards were somehow
tied to perhaps those intrinsic rewards
i would be more inclined to to
vote for something like this the other
issue that i have is that this is one
million dollars to the department of
education
non-lapsing
with little or no accountability
and once again i don't think we should
be spending government money
without a lot of accountability on it
and particularly to um
you know whether you say it's a trust
issue um i i want it down in writing
what what's actually going to happen and
and all these intrinsic awards have
a well-rounded policy on how they
determine it the governor's wife is on
the teacher of the year
committee and and
speaks highly of their
insight where they go to schools and
they actually see what's happening and
you know they make some judgments about
um
with all the data as well um so i would
just say that if you're if you're going
to do something like this just don't
throw money
um and particularly in a one million
dollar fund that's non-lapsing when you
don't have any criteria and you don't
have any
committee and that sort of thing
thank you sure well obviously there
would be criteria to develop of course
and uh
that would be
determined um
and this would as i said as a sponsor
see it uh representative this would be
new money okay so
one question that inevitably would come
to someone who would would express some
of your your sentiments would be you
know why would you not want to
find some new money to uh however much
or
or little to uh make available to to to
schools
that's one thought
the
teacher of the year
award uh
those are uh
well intended and wonderful
uh very subjective as you all know i
mean
there's great subjectivity to so many
awards i mean um
if you
whether it's all-star teams or national
honor society or whatever recognitions
um there's a large degree of
subjectivity in in those
the thing about
having a criteria in metrics actually
that takes out a lot of the subjectivity
and allows the award to be
granted strictly on the numbers rather
than on you know politics of who knows
who or who you know you mentioned the
governor's wife or whatever
so that's another uh
piece of this puzzle is is having some
some metrics as opposed to you know and
i want to make another point i know your
hand is up uh
when this came up before
at some point someone mentioned um
merit pay and and i this is not about
merit pay um i i have problem i mean i
love the concept of merit pay
but having been
like most of you been in the world of
education that's a very difficult thing
to do this is not about teacher merit
pay this is about strictly identifying
improvement and acknowledging and
rewarding it
uh may i just respond since you said you
couldn't understand why i wouldn't want
to put more money in certification i do
want to put more money into education
but again you're you're just throwing
money out to a million dollars
to the department of education
non-lapsing and again it's it's
the the subjectivity
in
the teacher of the year award um i think
if you talk to the people on that
committee it would not be
political it would not be
subjective it takes in people making
recommendations it takes in a lot of uh
other things it's just like the the um
krista mcauliffe uh scholarship
um but it they also have criteria for
schools and there's a lot of components
on we talked about this with every
student succeeds that you know the
measure of a school is not just their
test scores but it's their growth it's
their graduation rate it's a lot of
other
um
really uh metrics that you can that you
can point to
i
in order to be a good
steward of taxpayer money i want to know
the metrics and i want to know who's
going to be actually on that committee
before i throw the million dollars that
way thank you
sure thank you and the million dollars
was what was in the
original
measure
it could
that's a nice round figure it could be
two million
more i i that's something for future
future discussion personally i'd like to
see
more than that if but uh
we're dealing with a million numbers for
for i mean a million dollars for
for now given that was what was in the
original measure representative hobson
thank you um i wanted to ask rep tanner
a question
um
so you mentioned um intrinsic awards and
i was wondering if you could describe
what an intrinsic award is uh sure i
have another part two part two
would you be agreeable to a committee of
stakeholders like when i was on the um
drinking water commission we award money
to districts in need
as long as they can show
you know xyz
we've got the
commissioner we've got members of the
committee we've got other stakeholders
throughout the drinking water
establishment would would that kind of a
committee that goes through the awards
um
whatever they be would that be something
that if was added to this bill could you
support it
thank you um for asking that question
one the intrinsic rewards are right now
for example the
the um
elementary in my district grantham
elementary received the elementary
school award
um they received a
commendation from the department of
education
that was it okay
and they did a lot of hard work for that
um and the same thing with the teacher
of the year award
it's intrinsic because it's in name only
i mean
you get it but you have to go through a
lot of hoops to get to it that's what
intrinsic award is or if you're on a
basketball team and you win division one
you get
little
um charms that say that you're a state
championship
team and that's intrinsic that that is
enough
of a reward for those people um to feel
very special about what they do okay and
in education
most teachers don't go into education
thinking they're going to be rich okay
and they go into it because they feel a
calling or they feel uh the reward is is
intrinsic to the job that you have
um
and you like to have enough money to
have a decent you know car and living
and that sort of thing
your committee that you had
faced there
it sounded like base their rewards on
need
and
i am
one thousand percent
in giving rewards and giving extra money
to school districts based on need that's
not what this this bill is about this
bill is about giving this department of
education 100 or million dollars
without knowing how they're going to
spend it or how they're going to dole it
out
with only the instruction that we want
it to reward
um
you know positive
things or high achievement
not necessarily high
high growth or whatever and as
representative ellison said um
my guess is it's going to go to hanover
and
wolfeboro and
you know the the schools that we already
know from the commission report
have a
high
base
sunapee the town that i represent has a
high
base and and we're able to support our
students to the max
so
and and yet the berlin berlin say it
wrong berlin and franklin and those
schools that need it based on need
um but also maybe have made tremendous
growth
would be a great recipient for something
like that
sure right
thank you for that i appreciate that um
back and forth
the other thing that i don't know if
we've talked about and i don't remember
if it was in the other you know one of
the other hearings this seems to be the
never-ending discussion um
but i thought we were talking about
rewards like uh like a field trip or a
field day or just money that you could
use for
fun
um and even in you know a i guess a
quote successful district
um
you know i know these kids aren't aren't
having any fun they're not going places
they're not going on field trips um
maybe they're coming to the state house
but i'm not hearing a lot of uh that
kind of reward so
just if anybody would want to talk about
you know could this be an opportunity
for kids to experience something outside
of the budget that's really it
to go back to what i said earlier to i
think to your point
uh or some version of this to move
forward then if the school suddenly had
uh a fifty thousand dollar award because
of
uh showing improvement in a standardized
test score they could you take that
fifty thousand dollars and actually do
quite
you know they could do fifty if a field
trip was a thousand blocks they could do
fifty field trips if they wanted that's
one way that i look at it i also want to
follow up on
the notion that the hanovers would be
the ones that would
most benefit from this again going back
to the the hearing
the intent of this would be
to schools would have whatever
assessment was identified as the
assessment that would be the basis for
the criteria
schools would be competing only against
themselves
so the
whatever their baseline is if they
improve it by
the criteria they improve by 10
investments decided then they get an
award
uh
i don't know what the threshold will be
that's to be determined i don't think we
in this work session or in the committee
as a whole should get in the weeds and
get too prescriptive other than to make
some
funding and support available for doe to
establish criteria to reward success now
if if the school is a low base in fact i
think representative tanner i think it's
kind of the opposite of what you kind of
were alluding to with hanover
hanover if their baseline is fairly high
because they're a higher performing
school for them to get that 10
improvement would be much harder for
hanover than say the
picker school clermont if claremont or
berlin or whoever if their initial
baseline is lower it's much easier for
the poor performing school to get that
10 in fact this came up in committee
hearing uh it's much
harder for a higher performing school
that's already got a high uh baseline to
get that 10 or 20 percent so i think
it's really kind of the the opposite
concern from what you express i think
it's it's the lower schools that will
have an easier time uh
improving their baseline score
sure representative tanner
schools that are like franklin and
newport and claremont are doing
everything that they can do to get the
kids to improve
and
they would have
a more difficult time to do a 10 or 20
improvement i mean you sound like it'd
be easy for them to do it's not
it's not easy at all if it was easy they
would be doing it right now
sure we're not casting any i hope i'm
mishearing you i'm not casting any
aspersions on any school all
i'm saying on behalf of the sponsors
is that
schools would simply be com
if some version of this move forward
schools would be competing against their
own
baselines their own their own selves and
those baselines are different you know
some have hired some of laura you know
it's it's not an issue of you know what
schools are
trying hard are doing now
it's very uh metric based um it is
proposed
representative hall
okay so i'm thinking about the
schools in regards to their test scores
already they are doing the best and it
kind of goes along with representative
um tanner they're working hard to get
their test scores up so the notion that
this
you know they put some money in front of
them and you know we're going to do
better i'm not so sure that that's
really accurate i mean i think the
schools
work to do their best on the test scores
and sometimes you hear about people you
know this kind of stuff ends up people
teaching to the test god i want to do
well on the test and that could be an
unintended consequence
um with something like this but i think
the money this in this case the money
comes after
the increase as opposed to giving the
money so that they do increase this is
going to say you're going to increase
your test scores and you're going to get
this money then you can buy it as you
said you can put on air conditioning or
whatever you want i don't know just
seems like
um
i think teachers work really hard right
now and doing their best
oh sure i agree as i just said to rip
center tanner i
i don't think i or anyone is casting any
aspersions on any district or any
teachers not doing their their best
but i think honestly uh
they're what the sponsors are trying to
do with this and other measures um i'm
sure i
that you've noticed that there's a
there's a
hunger on the part of many
or
many parents and
and
people who care about education
to
see
a different paradigm uh it goes back to
the very beginning when we talked about
uh
is representative luna got into the
the school funding committee
was rethinking it's the way you looked
at the third grade test scores
um so
again as i've already said
we talk about innovation and here's
something that's a little bit innovative
rewarding success in some fashion
with the criteria to be determined
so again it doesn't cast dispersions on
and it's not intended to cast as persons
on anyone or any school other than to
try to
have a new incentive
or reward you know rewarding success as
i've already said i do want to
ask
i'm not sure
we don't have everybody here in like
with the last area
we probably won't take a vote or try to
take a vote but i do want to get the
subcommittee's sense on
if something were to move forward
like this in some fashion someday
somehow
uh
it sounded like from the hearing that
transferring from the rainy day fund
was not the right way to go
representative walls pointed out during
the hearing
when the bill was introduced that there
were probably issues with
transferring money from the rainy day
fund unless it's an emergency my
response was
you know we hear that education needs
money and some call it emergency
so that was my short answer to her but i
think
uh her point was well taken
so
let me see if we have a consensus
whether this shouldn't should not go
forward that's not my question but if
someday some version of this went
forward
do we agree that it should not come from
the rainy day fund but it should be it
should be a separate line item that's my
question
is it fair to
assume that we
all agree that the rainy day fund would
not be the way to go
is that is that fair to say
is there anyone who faces i think it was
more
uh
the procedure to get it i mean
it was it it wasn't where it comes from
so much as the mechanic the process uh
that that uh representative walls was
speaking to is that you
that has to go through the finance
committee and it it also has to be you
know the rainy day the emergency fund
has certain requirements in order to get
into it so we can't legislate oh just
dump a million into the doe every year
and let it lapse
well you mean when you say dump it in
you talk about
we
should not be
legislating that we take money out of
the rainy day fund for this purpose
correct we can't
that's right that's what that's what she
said and i and i i just said i think she
was onto something i think
that you know you we can try to make the
argument that we could do it but it's
it sounds like that it's not the way to
go so
so for my notes can
i want to put that we're all in
agreement that
as the bill originally came to this
committee with the
transfer from the rainy day fund we we
all agree that that's not the way to go
is that fair to say i won't be able to
um
yeah
i couldn't hear you well i'm sorry i my
my feeling is that what mary beth said
and she's been on finance forever is
that you can't do it that way
you can't just put it in a bill it's got
a it's got to be a process
sure so in my notes um i just want to
make sure that that
we're all
in agreement that we
agree with representative walls and
whoever
said
pointed out concerns about the way this
was originally
proposed that the rainy day fund
uh that approach is is not what we
think it works or is is
yeah i i i i think what what uh what
mirabeth was saying is the rainy day
fund is not an option
for this it's not whether we want to or
we think it should and shouldn't be it's
it's it's not available for this it's
not our decision
yeah unless you were to change the rainy
day fund statute
right correct so
the the one note that i
have a bunch of notes here i'll share
with all of you so i'm going to put down
that we agree that the bill is
originally introduced calling for a
rainy day fund transfer
we don't recommend that
and if this were to ever move forward it
would have to be funded otherwise
correct
okay
all right good so that's
that's a plus
um
other thoughts on
any aspect of this incentive grant sure
uh richard hobson sorry i keep butting
in uh
i was wondering if we put restrictions
on
you could only
receive the award one time
you can't continually
get the award year after year for
showing improvement
so like you know rye high school could
only get it one time
um
or potentially even
setting up i'm channeling my inner
uh school superintendent during um
uh
union contract negotiations he got down
to the fine details
if we
put requirements or
parameters around
maybe schools in need versus
qualifying
schools in need and those and not not in
need
financially or otherwise 50 of the
awards if we got down to that kind of
detail within these
awards would that be something of
interest
to
all parties
sure thank you
go ahead uh david and i had a thought on
that too no thanks thanks mike and and
deb i mean i think i think
you're on to something there however
um
i guess uh you know i i i guess the the
problems when it comes to to school
districts having access to the funds
they need
um to have strong student outcomes
universally across the uh the state and
every district is such a great problem
that as we spend every hour
of our group
on on this
we're not putting our mind share and our
time on solving i think a much more
significant problem for students and
taxpayers across the state
and and yeah we could
come up with a 35-page bill on how to
spend a million dollars a year on
on incentivizing schools
some that have access to forty five
thousand dollars per pupil and some that
have access to eleven thousand dollars
per pupil something even less than that
less than that
um uh in terms of um
having good student outcomes
and um and you know what it's probably
it's probably a lot easier for uh for a
school district that has access to forty
five thousand dollars per student
um
uh in terms of um maybe maybe working
this a little bit use the example of rye
i'm not quite sure where they're at i
don't think they're at 40 45 but i did
get a call from um
from somebody in response to
one of the rye school board
members
actually she's a state rep from rye
she gotten a phone call from one of the
rye school board members asking why rise
getting a million plus
back this year because they don't get
money back from the state for adequacy
but they did because of the um the
budget bill that uh that
reduced uh swept by 100 million dollars
and actually included a 15 million
dollar supplemental grant to the excess
swept towns who are losing money so rye
was getting somewhere close to 100 to a
million dollars uh back back for that
and she was incredible incredulous about
this that that there's other districts
that need it more
and and um and rightly so
um
this
bill just doesn't contemplate that at
all
and and it it doesn't help to address
and make things better in pittsfield or
newport or berlin or claremont or
manchester
um
and uh and frankly it does i i think you
know
provide some
some um you know additional opportunity
for districts that can afford to
i mean who who
you know who have access to tremendous
financial resources to apply those
resources in different ways uh in terms
of winning a fifty thousand dollar award
and doing something with that for their
student body um um uh i'm not
not against it but i am against spending
our mind sharing our time
on um on working on this when when much
much more significant problems are
facing the state
uh
one of your points about uh criteria in
how much we should get involved with
with that my personal vision of this is
to be is is to not be prescriptive
basically to cut this
right to the to the number that
uh
i and others would like to simply make
some extra money available
for doe to reward success simple as that
and then um
in terms of
which assessment would be used yet we
we've had some informal conversations
kaitlyn davis had said she had a
recommendation at some point if it ever
gets to that point
uh which assessment could she would
recommend to be used
once that assessment
say this moves forward which i belong
obviously i believe in it
in fact i think it can do a lot of good
in a lot of ways so it is worth our time
and i think that uh
many people out there i don't know me
many folks are watching on youtube or
will watch on youtube but uh i know that
many people
applaud or would applaud or will applied
us trying to create a little extra money
to reward success and
which assessments can be used or the
criteria to be used uh
then i don't think that's for us to get
into the weeds to do let's find
my thinking let's find some money make
it available to doe
and let them develop the criteria and
uh maybe
let's
try this
hate to see the perfect be the enemy of
the good and that's our job is what we
do is ask questions whoever brings a
bill in we pick it apart and ask
troubleshoot and ask questions which is
good
but uh i think too often really good
things
don't move forward because we we
get wrapped up with the
perfect being the enemy the good anyway
so
to your question or point about criteria
uh
i would
just trust d.o.e
let him have let him have a million
dollars one time say it works maybe
it'll work great and so there's another
million dollars it goes to
20 different schools 50 000 and in the
process if some approaches are used or
shared that how did they improve they
did this i think there's great value to
that but again that's that's my opinion
um other
thoughts on any piece of this
if not before we
and again uh i'm not going to look to
try to have a vote uh we don't have all
the assigned people here uh although
this is apparently on youtube for people
to look at and we can come back to it
while attorney fend is here um i i would
like to if i could get a little bit of a
sense from her if she
can convey any uh
thoughts from anyone from the d.o.e side
again
as i mentioned earlier several of us
that have
chatted informally with folks from d.o.e
to include the commissioner on on on the
concept of
rewarding success
and there's
there was
significant interest in the concept
um
so anyway uh attorney finan
does anybody have any doe type questions
for diana while she's here
on how doe might
look at this beyond what they've some of
the folks there have said informally uh
representative tanner never pass up it
opportunity to ask diana question
is there any reason that there's not any
monetary reward to the teacher of the
year or to the school districts that
succeed now that are recognized for
excellence in education at the various
levels
and their runners-up
uh for the record diana fenton with the
department of ed um to the best of my
knowledge there's been no financial
appropriation for those
for those groups um i don't know the
logic behind it and the reasoning behind
it and the political decision making
behind it which i think is really the
crux of your question i'm not privy to
that information
let me ask representative question along
those lines if at some point and down
the road in the future some version of
this bill
uh is introduced
would you support
a
measure of funding to go to d.o.e to do
what you just described to to reward
whoever's wins the
teacher of the year or whatever
i would support
funding to go to the intrinsic rewards
that we now
give like teacher of the year and the
recognition of excellence in education
in the various levels
through the committees that are
currently set up to do that
with the with the criteria that they
have
on a non uh
rather than give them money to doe to
then give out i would give it to the
committees that are set up
right now to award those and i would try
to get businesses to support it i mean
businesses are interested in you know
you talk about taking money from the
rainy day fund a lot of businesses are
are really interested in supporting
education and as you said probably would
be interested in rewarding
um high performance
and i would i would say try to get
business sponsorship for for these
things and and uh encourage that
so i'm trying to understand your answer
to my question um
you my question was would you given what
you said about teacher of the year would
you support
funding from the state
that would be earmarked to reward
teacher of the year
if it was done
through the same criteria with the same
type of committees that they now have my
concern is the accountability of just
giving a million dollars to doe and
letting doe
set up the criteria
make the awards
and lapse the fun you know have
non-lapsing funds so that this amount of
money keeps building up i that's my
my issue so
uh yes i i fully would support uh
funding these different awards these
intrinsic awards
you're using with the state
appropriation earmark for that but my my
um yes state but i also think that it
would be a great idea to try to get
and try to get businesses
uh just like
grappone ford um you know supports the
crtc in concord um i'm sure there are a
lot of businesses that would put money
uh into a fund to do that
i think that businesses are asked to
contribute to the teacher of the year
um
what that looks like i'm not sure but i
know that i've had those discussions i
know i've participated in some of those
um
some of that the communication and the
outreach as it pertains to that um i do
want to talk about
kind of the criteria which has been a
point of big big discussion here so
as currently written this bill provides
for rulemaking under 541a
and so this
uh this would be set up the way that a
lot of other programs are set up at the
doe whether it's a robotics initiative
grant um this past legislative session
there was a
co-curricular activities bill
and those are smaller amounts
fifty thousand dollars for four thousand
dollar grants to school districts
and
in each robotics and the co-curricular
the department has rule making authority
to create what those programs look like
what the criteria is
in terms of your concern about
accountability
there are a lot of statutes that require
the department to submit a report to the
legislature
every year to document what that looks
like i don't know if that fully
addresses your concern but that is
something that we've seen in other
in other bills
attorney you mentioned about robotics
awards the uh
the monies that are associated with that
in those awards where do those monies
come from
i i would have to look at
each individual
bill but my understanding is i mean we
can look at the co-curricular bill that
was passed this last session
i don't remember the number off the top
of my head but hold on
special
to include special uh olympic
athletes into different groups
co-curricular
um
i have my chart hold on
good
i was almost there 16 24.
thank you
um i mean it doesn't have to be based on
that but that's certainly
a framework
anytime there's an appropriation to doe
for grants to districts i always go back
to robotics
and then the co-curricular it gives you
a framework on how you can structure
this
because i know both of those bills
robotics and co-curricular those went
through an enormous amount of work to
get to the final product and so i know
representative mullen was a co-sponsor
on the co-curricular
bill and
that didn't pass the first time around
and one of the things that she looked at
was robotics and we were very the
department is very successful in
creating the rules by which those grants
were then distributed to districts i
don't know if there was a um
a report required
of the accountability piece
in those programs i don't recall that
there might have been for robotics but i
don't recall off the top of my head but
there are other bills by which the
department is held accountable
and usually you see that in the form of
reporting back
to the legislature in some form or
fashion
just a note on the co-curricular bill
that uh that you just alluded to
i was the original sponsor of that we
started out two terms ago is a is a
unified sports bill
that has had a circuitous journey uh
represent vlad uh laying
the next year uh took took it over but
fyi that bill it rips and moan and i are
both co-sponsors going to the governor's
desk next week
uh so that is a uh
is a success story and that involved a
fifty thousand dollar
it had a financial love it was a fifty
thousand dollar piece of that and that
is going to the governor next week
so that is a success story but it took
three terms and and financed financial
committee and uh
tweaking and
anyway uh
but i'm very interested to hear as i
look at uh 541a and the and contemplate
the
the reality that there's a model already
in place that does using to
make financial awards to support um
excellence in robotics that's that
exists correct well i will correct your
language just slightly it's not to
reward excellence in robotics
it is a grant program
for um and again i don't have the
language of the bill in front of me but
it is for startup programs so that
districts can have either a club or a
program um
for
for their students and so it was to pay
for um
i don't know anything about robotics i'm
embarrassed to admit but um you know
just the startup materials
for those types of clubs i don't think
it was allowed to pay for the stipend
um it would not pay for things like
t-shirts or anything like that it was a
focus on getting the material so that a
district who did not have a robotics
club previously could have that
opportunity for for their students and
then if there was money left over the
leftover money could go to support an
existing club and so what we saw around
the state um was that people were
taking advantage of this opportunity to
bring in a resource that maybe their
district didn't have previously and then
i think that idea went into the
co-curricular activities
bill with the same kind of idea
recognizing that some districts already
have this in place and might need
support to continue it and others would
need that startup money so it wasn't to
reward excellence it wasn't to recognize
districts that already had it and was
achieving something it was to to just
bring opportunity to districts that did
not have it and that would be very
different than what is proposed um
in front of us now but i think the
i always call it the infrastructure
the infrastructure by which the
department could administer those that
program if this bill were to pass
is already in place we would simply
transfer that infrastructure to this
idea
in this concept
thank you very much for making note uh
that the you just explained that the
infrastructure essentially is in place
um to
implement
a uh
awarding you know providing grants to
districts they qualify that meet the
criteria
sure that meet criteria i mean we have
created criteria by which we say if you
want to start a robotics program this is
what we're looking for and we are
prepared to do the same with a
co-curricular
bill
um
yeah so so that
piece is in place in terms of the rule
making and there was some discussion
about that
in general terms when the department
engages in rulemaking
whatever the rule making is for whether
it's
for social studies teaching certificate
or or whatever it is
um
we always work with stakeholders
and i i have not seen a bill
that sets out who those stakeholders
should be
i'm not familiar with with ever seeing a
law that has set out who the
stakeholders shall be
but just in terms of our rule making
process
we always just
do that as a matter of course um
and then as part of the rule making
process
all the rules that are proposed do go to
a public hearing and so the public has
the opportunity to look at what is
proposed by the department come before
the state board
and
voice their concern or their opinion uh
in support of it and so that's just a
little insight into our rule making
process
thank you it's very interesting here
that
what you described about the
infrastructure that currently exists to
do what is currently being done
potentially being a uh
something that could be copied in some
fashion for other initiatives it sounds
like i mean that's certainly our plan
for the um
for
1624 um
that's the co-curricular bill yeah bill
um and i know that
you know we
that came from
when representative mullen uh was
was testifying uh to that bill i think
last session or maybe even two sessions
ago
and i think it was itled in house
finance division two
and so the discussion there was this
needs more structure
and the thought was similar to the
robotics grant incentive program
which i mean i don't know how you
measure it but it seemed to be a very
successful initiative
um and so that was her thought to kind
of rework the bill and that moving
forward is what ultimately passed and i
know there was continuous discussion
about that this session in house finance
and certainly from my perspective at the
department is we look at rulemaking and
it's interesting because that bill
i'll just bring this to your attention
now because i just realized it
in the rule making it's a may it's not a
show i've never seen a may for rule
making so now i'm all befuddled as to
what i do
but my problem not yours um
but you know when we look at this
that's based on robotics and so my
thought it doesn't have to be but my
thought is
any time that the department is going to
be tasked with issuing grants that are
based on criteria of some sort
we will go back to look at what worked
in the past what can be
made better but yes we have that
infrastructure in place to do that
thank you very much for that
are the questions for
attorney fountain
thanks so much
i have no further questions for the
witness i i feel i i purposely did not
sit in the chairman's chair because i'm
not
not worthy of the old days
so we have an hour plus that we have on
youtube presumably that people can
uh alicia's not here as with this
morning that is there for uh
people to look at
uh
i'm not gonna try to have a vote on any
met any emotions
unless the whole group is here
um so i as i said with most of you here
for the other the other session i'll
organize some notes
and um
share the notes with everyone and then
once we all agree that whatever notes
uh reflect our back and forth i'll send
that to the chair
and then um
we can come back to things in september
once people
can look at the youtubes or here
and other folks can weigh in as well
uh
anything else uh that's where i'm at
i'll
i'll put the words together for you all
anything else
well
uh there's a motion on the floor i guess
in this working session uh yeah if
there's
nothing else be added um i'll work on
some notes and we'll press on in the
and whoever's watching on youtube thanks
thanks for watching
for the record that's representative
hobson is freezing under the air
conditioning
thanks again
you